in today's morning rounds a new warning
about painkiller addiction and how it
can start after a common surgery about 5
million Americans choose to have their
wisdom teeth removed every year most of
these procedures happen in the summer
and most are adolescents and young
adults ages 17 to 21 Meg Oliver is here
with what patients and parents need to
know to avoid the dangers of addiction
Tony good morning listen closely to
these numbers the American Dental
Association says after updating its
guidelines advising against prescribing
opioids dentist wrote almost half a
million fewer prescriptions in 2017
compared to five years earlier but with
18 point 1 million filled the numbers
are still staggering and some families
are living with devastating consequences
everything that she could do to teach
Julianne new things that was her
favorite things watching him learn
Julianne was her life oh yeah
Ellen Early's daughter sage was a young
mother doting on her 16 month old son
Julian that day at the dentist's office
must haunt you yeah very much in 2017
the 22 year old needed to have her
wisdom teeth removed the dentist
prescribed the opioids right did he give
any warning no no warning no nothing in
fact he said you know I think they gave
her a five-day supply and he said if you
need more just let me know just give a
call sage quickly became dependent
getting several refills before she found
something else how quickly did it go
from opioids to heroin almost
immediately just 15 months after having
her wisdom teeth removed
sage overdosed and died in an airport
bathroom on her way to a fourth round of
rehab it was shocking and she was gone
but mostly gone from Julian that was the
shocking part I've heard many stories
that are similar to this one dr. Chad
Brummett studies pain at the University
of Michigan he says despite research
showing that a combination of
acetaminophen and ibuprofen is superior
to treat pain dentists are still
prescribing too many opioids for many
dental care such as wisdom teeth
extraction is
first opioid exposure could be like
50,000 kids each year becoming new
chronic opioid users after just
something simple like a wisdom tooth
extraction dr. Braam its research found
that simply filling an opioid
prescription after wisdom tooth surgery
more than doubled the odds of continued
use among patients who had never used
those painkillers before in light of the
epidemic
the American Dental Association has
released updated guidelines recommending
use of alternative pain relievers and a
maximum seven-day supply when opioids
are necessary nice to meet you dr. Joel
Furnari started cutting back on writing
opioid prescriptions more than five
years ago they don't have to fill it I
asked them just to take it and have it
available as a tool 80% of doctor for
Nori's patients never filled the opioid
prescription he believes taking the time
to educate that reduces the likelihood
they'll actually use it he is keeping
swelling down Allen early hopes more
families learn about the alternatives to
opioids after dental surgery almost a
year after a sages death her grandson
keeps asking when his mom is coming back
and he remembers her and he says you
know he'll take me into her room and say
well let's just wait let's just wait for
mama to come home that must break your
heart oh absolutely absolutely Julian is
now three and will start preschool this
fall dr. Braam at the University of
Michigan researcher told me it's still
common practice for oral surgeons to
write that backup prescription but he
says it's misguided and potentially
detrimental his message to families
across the country this morning you do
not need opioids for standard wisdom
tooth surgery maybe not right the
prescription then is this a common thing
in dentistry and get opioid
prescriptions they write it as a back up
because they get worried that they might
have severe pain it might happen
overnight where you can't fill a
prescription at that point or on a
weekend but dr. Brummett is saying that
that combination of a sediment if in an
ibuprofen that's
Pirie or form of treatment for this type
of surgery all right thank you